pour françois xavier dugourd la partie
n'est pas terminée
écarté en juin dernier au profit
dernière chance pour reconquérir la
première circonscription de côte-d'or
il conteste haut et fort cette décision
prise selon lui irrégulièrement par la
commission d'investiture des
républicains il n'y avait uniquement 15
membres présents alors qu'il en faut au
minimum 40 pour que la décision puisse
être prise correctement donc j'ai fait
un recours qui s'appuie sur cet élément
factuel extrêmement possible il
yad'autres et des banques qui s'y
ajoutent donc ce recours sera examiné en
novembre
et puis définitivement en décembre ses
noces et nos statuts
c'est le conseil national des
républicains qui décidera qui sera le
candidat des républicains sur cette
circonscription
le premier vice président du conseil
départemental ancré sur ce territoire
depuis 12 ans s'estime plus légitime
mais aussi victime de la parité
obligatoire
c'est un peu réducteur de penser que
quelqu'un était investi parce que c'est
une femme on a tous déposé un dossier il
n'y avait pas qu'une photo de femme
dessus il y avait aussi des compétences
il ya aussi un parcours alors certes je
n'ai pas un parcours politique je n'ai
pas fait une carrière politique mais je
suis investi depuis longtemps dans le
milieu économique dijonnais j'aime dijon
et
je pense que j'ai un gros atout du fait
que je suis issu de la société civile
le président de la fédération des
républicains de côte d'or soutien à mr
chance qui est aussi sa suppléante à
l'assemblée nationale rémy de lattes
appelle au respect et au rassemblement
d'autant qu'une autre candidature de
droite celle de bernard depierre et déjà
confirmé sur cette première
circonscription appartement où il ya eu
un arbitrage
il faut s'y tenir j'ajoute que la parité
est année dont important aujourd'hui
dans la représentation nationale et on
sait combien des français y sont
attachés
on sait aussi tout toutes les
contraintes qui sont liées à la vie des
formations politiques autour de la
parité
voilà il se trouve que sur la première
circonscription anr chance est investi
le résultat de la primaire de la droite
et du centre pourrait aussi redistribué
les cartes
le sarkozyste dugourd espère donc encore
revenir en première ligne
début décembre